denial-of-service attacks have been in
the news recently and the recent ones
have been something called amplified
distributed denial-of-service attacks
um this is a fairly straightforward
thing but how we got here is quite
interesting denial of service attacks
have gone on for a long long long long
time I can remember being 1415 and going
on IRC which is like Internet Relay Chat
like an old school our chat service and
irritating people an IRC to this day
remains a haven for the kind of script
kiddie type the the cracker type the
type that has downloaded a few slightly
dodgy scripts off the internet and
thinks they are now an extremely good
hacker because of it and I may have
irritated like 14-year old me maybe
rotated a couple of these times and my
home internet connection got denial of
service at that point my home internet
connection was a 56k modem it is
incredibly easy to denial-of-service
attack those particularly if you happen
to irritate someone who is on an
enormous university connection at say 1
Meg which isn't that much bigger by
today's standards but in those days all
it meant is they set up a little thing
on their system which sends as much
traffic as possible to your system and
if their system is bigger than yours
well your internet connection gets
saturated you can't send anything in and
out at which point I have to literally
hang up the phone dial in again and get
a new IP address so they can't find me
and that was how it worked for a while
and then you start to get the the
criminals involved who were writing
botnets who are writing viruses that
instead of destroying data would go in
and take over other people's internet
connections they would find our
broadband users general in the United
States or around there who would who
would be running unsecured versions of
Windows XP or 98 or something like that
they would quietly install their
software in the background and then
would use those unsuspecting users
internet connections to launch a big
denial of service attack this was
distributed denial of service so instead
of having one big computer you had lots
of little computers hundreds maybe even
thousands maybe tens of thousands all
sending as much traffic as they could
against one company and it didn't matter
how big that company's internet
connection was ultimately ten thousand
people all reloading their website or
tend them much traffic as possible as
fast as possible yeah it's going to take
down their net connection and what was
this useful well ransom what you found
in in sort of the 2000s was that
gambling companies are finance companies
anyone whose job whose livelihood
depended on being up and online all the
time
was being held for ransom they would get
a call or an email or or a message that
said if you don't pay as an amount your
website's going to go down for quite a
while there are defense strategies sort
of you can generally hire a very
expensive company to try and mitigate
this at which point it does become a bit
of a protection racket but ultimately
Microsoft got their act together the
number of zombie computers as they were
called started falling down and the
internet started getting more and more
and more and more bandwidth and you get
higher in that connection that could
stand up to a reasonable denial of
service attacks for not too much now the
new threat is something called amplified
denial of service and it's not a new
threat as such it's it's just a new
common threat it's been theorized about
for a while and what it is is a
combination of a couple of
vulnerabilities and have some very old
parts of the internet work hold that
thought because I need you explain
something else first I need to explain
the difference between TCP and UDP TCP
is how most of the web works
it's how the web page that you're
viewing the YouTube page you're viewing
that's in get sent back and forth and it
is a two-way protocol there's a
handshake involved you request something
and then that request is acknowledged
and you get something back and as all
the packets go back and forth those
there's two-way conversation going on
making sure that everything is arrived
in the right order intact which means
you can use it for webpages you use it
for our financial transactions on your
online bank you can use it for anything
we're getting everything through bit
perfect is required and then on the
other hand you have UDP UDP is very much
opposite of that UDP is here is a stream
of data just just deal with it as much
as it as much as you can
as fast as you can just just deal with
it this is what you use for voice over
IP this is what you use for streaming
video live video anything where it
doesn't matter if a bit of it gets lost
or a bit of it arrives in the wrong
order
I say bit a part of it obviously bit is
a thing it does matter if some of it
arrives a little bit malformed as long
as most of it gets through now the
difference between those is that UDP
doesn't really have a handshake you just
kind of point a firehose of data or
something and blast them with it
and because of that well it means you
don't really have to acknowledge it you
don't have to say yes I approve this
stream being sent to me it just kind of
arrives and there's not much you can do
about it there is a flaw in the UDP
protocol or leasing some implementations
of it and a few other subtle things
around the internet that means I can
essentially spoof the return address on
my computer here can claim that I'm
someone else entirely and that wouldn't
normally be a problem because most well
design protocols and pretty much
everything in the Internet will only let
you send on a small amount of data I
send a small request to them they send a
small request on words and it's not
really a problem except there is
something called MTP the network time
protocol and this is the thing that
keeps all the clocks in your phone and
your laptop in sync to almost to the
millisecond wonderful thing great boon
to society unfortunately has a couple of
really badly designed things in it and
one of them is this command mon list
this is the most useless frustrating and
abused command ever added to anything
it's horrible what it does is it sends
the details of the last 600 people who
requested the time from that computer
back I I have no idea why you'd add that
I have absolutely no idea why that
exists why you would need the last 600
people why 600 anyway what it means is
that I can send a tiny request just as
little mana list command here to the
time server and the time servers are all
on enormous connections spoof where it
came from and they will send I mean no
this amount of data 206 times the amount
of data to that poor computer there and
more than that and work out where this
is going you know there are many time
servers and let's say I have one of
those botnets that I mentioned earlier
with zombie computers those compromised
computers can all send small amounts of
data to lots of time servers and they
will all send 206 times the amount of
data to this poor sod
this is NTP amplification but it's not
the only amplification attack that's
been DNS for a while there are a couple
of others that security researchers are
hinting at but don't wanna release the
details of not because that'll stop the
bad guys it won't you can't do security
through obscurity that's the term but
you might at least slow them down a bit
if you're watching this a few months
after it's been uploaded I wouldn't be
surprised if we've seen one maybe two
terabit per second attacks that is a
hundred thousand times more than your
broadband connection it's something that
is on the scale of disrupting the entire
internet rather than just disrupting one
computer how can you defend against it
well you can't I mean you can hire a
company that that claims to be able to
block a lot of attacks and they can and
they can do interesting things at the
network level to try and filter it all
out but ultimately against an attack of
that size which could actually disrupt
the infrastructure of the internet
itself there's not much a victim can do
but you can do is campaign to get the
relays the amplification vectors shut
down and we've seen this done before we
saw it with open mail relays years ago
there used to be things called open mail
relays which would be just simple sites
that would take an email and forward it
on and those were incredible vectors for
spam and they were blocked and they were
filtered and they were shut down
campaigned against for a long long time
there's now a a generally agreed upon
list of these still open which just
won't be able to send anywhere because
everyone simply ignores their traffic
this is going to happen sooner or later
with relays that still allow spoofing
and relays it still allow amplification
attacks sooner or later they will get
shut down
it until then well just kind of have to
hope that no one targets you we'd like
to thank audible.com for sponsoring this
computerphile video and if you'd like to
check out one of their huge range of
books get over to audible.com slash
computerphile and there's a chance to
download one for free I'd like to
recommend a book today called makers by
Chris Anderson which is all about the
idea of democratizing the world of
making things and manufacturing so the
idea is that the Internet has a
democratized publishing and broadcasting
with things like YouTube and then it the
same thing is happening to the world of
bits and stuff and kind of covers a
hacker movement so get over there check
that out remember audible.com
computerphile for your chance to
download a free book and thanks once
again to them for sponsoring this
computerphile video